bonsoir frédéric saint clair merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france que
pensez vous de cette manifestation qui
se tient en plein état d'urgence
sanitaire le conseil d'état ce soir
d'ailleurs à lever cette interdiction de
manifester qu'en pensez vous j'en pense
que le conseil d'état y complaisant
comme bien souvent
et comme le gouvernement et donc qu'on
se retrouve avec bien évidemment une
inégalité criante entre les territoires
où les personnes sont strictement
contrôlés avec une impossibilité de se
déplacer de se rassembler à plus de 10
et puis d'autres territoires qui pour
des raisons très discutable sont libres
de droits alors on a entendu ce cette
déclaration de six bêtes ndiaye qui dit
qu'il faut ouvrir finalement le le débat
sur les statistiques ethniques certains
justifié les contrôles au faciès par le
fait que la délinquance se situe dans
dans certaines zones avec certaines
catégories de population est ce que vous
pensez que c'est un c'est un débat à
voir alors écoutez la problématique et
et complexes on va on va apprendre s'il
voulait bien une petite minute pour
mettre les choses à plat donc sur les
statistiques ethniques c'est un outil
absolument indispensable pour que les
chercheurs puissent travailler non pas
pour qu'on puisse faire de la
discrimination positive ce qui est
demandé par les associations qui sont
pour l'ouverture ou l'autorisation de de
collecte de données explique sais c'est
que derrière il ya une idéologie qui
consiste à dire on va favoriser
certaines communautés
or l'article 1er de notre constitution
dit que il n'ya pas de distinction des
individus en fonction de leur religion
de leur origine ou de leur race c'est à
dire de leurs couleurs sont les termes
exacts de la constitution d'une autre
statistique voilà en france d'où
l'interdiction en france actuellement
que ces tests de ces statistiques
exactement et qui pourtant serait utile
pour avoir un regard sociologique plus
juste de la composition de notre pays d
origine des personnes des flux entrants
et sortants et des 10
en catégorie de population en fonction
des différents endroits c'est un outil
d'étude qui sert à penser la société pas
qui sert aux politiques à discriminer
entre les personnes en fonction de leur
couleur ce qui est non seulement
contraire à l'article 1er de la
constitution mais surtout contraire à la
l'esprit de notre république qui fait du
citoyen français
un citoyen qui a une appartenance à la
collectivité qui est de nature politique
et culturelle c'est ça qui fait le socle
de notre appartenance république n est
pas la couleur
et aujourd'hui ce qui est j'allais dire
traumatisant pour une partie des
français qui regardent ces images là
c'est que depuis des années il
il pensait qu'il y avait une volonté
globale d'aller vers une société qui est
de moins en moins racialisées et
aujourd'hui ce racialisme est
instrumentalisée par des minorités
politiques ils ont font un combat de
premier plan et ramène l'ensemble de la
nation à des problématiques qui
n'avaient plus cours depuis longtemps
c'est à dire que le discours est
extrêmement diffusé on a l'impression
qu'il ya une masse énorme de français
qui sont pris par ces problématiques
racialiste alors qu'en réalité ce n'est
qu'une toute petite minorité
deux personnes très politisée qui
veulent utiliser instrumentaliser ces
débats sur les couleurs pour faire
chuter la république vous dites donc
contrairement à d'autres que ce n'est
pas un système que ce n'est pas un
système installé en france
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
républicains qui disent que ça peut
arriver partout finalement jeudi
jeudi deux choses jeudi la première les
yahia deux problématiques et sont posé
la première c'est ce que la police est
raciste la deuxième c est ce que la
police est violente
je vais je vais bousculé un tout petit
peu les idées reçues est ce que la
police est raciste non est-ce qu'il ya
du racisme dans la police anecdotique
est ce que la police est violente
la réponse et la police n'est pas
suffisamment violente cette réponse là
vous ne l'entendez nulle part ailleurs
parce que nulle part ailleurs ne pense
le politique
c'est à dire expliquez vous il faut que
je m'explique effectivement donc
fondamentalement ce qui aujourd'hui
donne du corps à cette idée que la
police ait trop violente
ce n'est pas les mouvements auxquels on
fait face aujourd'hui c'est le souvenir
qu'on a des gilet jaune
c'est ça qui aujourd'hui résonnent dans
la pensée d'une grande partie des
français qui dit mais si la police est
trop violente puisque regarder les gilet
jaune
le nombre de personnes qui ont été et
bornier alors c'étaient de simples
manifestants qui ont eu des mains
arrachées
en réalité ce n'est pas que la police
ait violent que la police ne peut pas
être autrement que violente
max weber un sociologue du début du
xxème siècle allemand a expliqué que
l'état est le seul détenteur de la
violence légitime cette violence
physique
cette violence de l'état du pouvoir
politique ne peut s'expliquer ne peut
s'exprimer que par la police
bistaki responsable oui la police doit
être violente elle doit être violente
à partir du moment où on trouve que la
police ait trop violente c'est parce que
le pouvoir politique n'est pas légitime
et donc là en ce moment se trompe de
procès on fait un procès à la police
c'est de pouvoir politique il faut faire
le procès c'est parce qu'il n'est pas
légitime que là que la violence de la
police n'est plus acceptable
et c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant les
gilet jaune
la violence de la police était
inacceptable parce que le pouvoir et
délégitimé croire qu'on peut aujourd'hui
maintenir un état moderne sans une
police suffisamment violente pour
répondre à la violence de la société
c'est un leurre
nous sommes en train d'affaiblir notre
police et donc d'affaiblir notre
république il faut se poser la question
de la légitimité du pouvoir politique
c'est ça la clé de compréhension pas de
la violence de la police si la police
n'est pas violente elle ne sert à rien
et si elle ne protège pas le citoyen et
l'état
à ce moment là la république chute je je
je tempère vos propos évidemment comme
par les violences et les âges de la
force que vous lanciez la violence
légitime sous les propos de max weber y
a pas besoin de tempérer le terme est
consacré les dans tous les manuels de
sciences politiques depuis un siècle
cette violence physique légitime veut
bien dire ce qu'elle veut dire elle est
proportionnée elle est adaptée à la
violence qui elle subit de la société
elle n'a qu'un seul objectif maintenir
l'ordre
public 1 sur notre pays au jour dans
notre pays aujourd'hui les français sont
tous d'accord d'un côté ils trouvent que
la police ait trop violente
d'un autre côté il trouve que l'ordre
républicain n'est pas maintenu il ya une
contradiction dans les termes
quand on sait la folie c'est trop
violente ça veut dire que l'ordre
républicain est maintenue s'il n'est pas
maintenue ça veut dire que la police
n'est pas assez violent donc il faut
trancher
en réalité le problème c'est la
légitimité du pouvoir politique que
pensez vous du fait que adama traoré
soit érigée en symbole de la lutte
contre le racisme aujourd'hui à l'image
de georges le fleuve
oui vous avez raison c'est une question
absolument centrale en réalité ça montre
7,7 symbolique qui est en train de
naître ça montre notre incapacité tout
d'abord à faire barrière contre l'
influence le soft power américain
vous remarquerez que depuis les années
60 nous nous amera qu american is dont
tout ce qui vient des états unis est
absorbée en france digérer aujourd'hui
ces jeunes gens dans votre reportage on
l'a entendu ont commencé par expliquer
que le genou à terre c'était une
symbolique en rapport à georges floyd
mais en réalité george frey n'est
absolument pas en question en france la
police américaine la police française
n'ont rien à voir les problématiques
raciale américaines et françaises n'ont
rien à voir donc
en fait de quoi on parle on parle de la
récupération pas un groupuscule
d'indigènes east de communautariste de
des colonialistes donc cccc groupes
politiques dont je parlais en début
d'interview qui aujourd'hui ont un seul
objectif
l'expression de ce que nietzsche appeler
une volonté de puissance c'est-à-dire
non pas l'égalité entre les personnes
mais le renversement du processus de
nomination ils véhiculent l'idée qu' ils
ont été eux et leurs ancêtres dominé par
les blancs pendant longtemps et que
maintenant il faut que les choses
changent leurs discours officiel c'est
il faut l'égalité pour tout le monde
mais dans les faits on remarque que
lynchage que caillassage que destitution
de statut de symbolique république
n y compris victor schoelcher y compris
des personnes qui ont été contre
l'esclavagé y compris gandhi qui est
probablement la figure la plus
spirituelle du monde du 20e siècle
donc cette volonté de domination et une
volonté de renversement du rapport de
domination
ils véhiculent l'idée qu'ils ont été
dominés pendant longtemps et que c'est à
eux maintenant de prendre leur revanche
c'est à dire de dominer les blancs on
est vraiment au niveau 0 0 du discours
politique
on a aboli tous les principes
républicains tous les principes des
droits de l'homme tout de l'histoire de
notre occident est probablement ce qui a
fait les plus belles heures de la
construction de la pensée des lumières
on est au niveau zéro de la politique
il n'ya que instrumentalisation il faut
que les élites et que la population soit
extrêmement vigilant parce qu on est
dans ce qu'on appelle une phase
régressive
merci beaucoup frédéric sinclair pour
votre analyse
merci je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france